bienvenue dans afrique connect nous
allons évoquer la présence chinoise en
afrique depuis vingt ans les
investissements de pékin sont telles que
l'on parle de la chinafrique une
expression devenue populaire et pour
cause est la chine est le premier
partenaire commercial de l'afrique le
principal bailleur de fonds des pays
africains pour vous donner une idée les
échanges commerciaux entre la chine et
les pays africains sont passés de 10
milliards de dollars en 2000 à 220
milliards de dollars en 2014 reste à
savoir si pour le continent africain il
s'agit d'un partenariat gagnant ou
perdant et pour évoquer cette
problématique et bien nous sommes avec
vous à damas gay vous êtes spécialiste
de la chine journaliste écrivain et
votre ouvrage sorti en 2013 est une
référence chine-afrique le dragon et
l'autruche aux éditions l'harmattan
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
dans ac connect c'est mon plaisir d'être
avec vous alors d'abord pourquoi à
l'époque ce titre le dragon et
l'autruche c'est que le dragon la chine
et l'autriche l'africain à l'époque déjà
le monde voyez émerger la chine en
économies
rugissante
qui bouleversait tout sur son passage et
menés pratiquement déjà la course en
tête en termes de leadership économique
au même moment le continent africain
quand même curieux de vivre des
difficultés dans sa gouvernance
économique dans ces évolutions
politiques
dans les problèmes que rencontrent ici
société et déjà on commençait à sentir
l'émergence de certains phénomènes
transnationaux terroristes sur le
continent africain a donc étudié tant
pour ce qui me concerne et de faire une
comparaison entre
les évolutions
contraste est de la chine
y devenir la première puissance
potentiellement au plan économique après
avoir été pendant longtemps un pays
vivant dans des difficultés traversant
des famines de conflit est à n'en plus
finir des invasions extérieur est
désormais
prenant le dessus sur tout ce qui lui
avait fait vivre ce que l'on a appelé le
siècle de l'humiliation de la chine de
1845 à
1945 jusqu'en 1949 la proclamation de la
république populaire de chine le 1er
octobre 1949
toute cette période là des difficultés
la chine semblait l'avoir lançant des
eaux le continent africain qui a
connu une phase de libération nationale
à partir de la fin des années 50 avec
les indépendances
était parti pourrait se dire sur un pied
d'égalité au plan économique en termes
de revenu par tête d'habitant beaucoup
de petits pays comme même le bowling et
vert en avance sur la chine
la chine avait pris le dessus en afrique
était en position de recul pourquoi cela
cet effet et donc je me suis posé la
question de savoir si nous n'avions pas
en face de nous d'une part une chine qui
était un dragon billettique très solide
et de l'autre des pays africains qui
était resté la tête enfouie dans le
sable on dit juste riche qu'il refusait
de voir que il avait fort à faire pour
pouvoir se mettre à jouer et jouer dans
la même ligue que la chine l'instar
premier regard sur la relation afrique
chine à travers cet ouvrage et vous
l'expliquer finalement de monde aux
antipodes qui aujourd'hui ne peuvent
plus se passer l'un de l'autre
absolument mais écoutez les relations
certes sur différentes en termes
d'évolution
la chine est pratiquement en passe même
s'il ne veut pas la m elle est en passe
de devenir une grande puissance
économique à elle n'est plus en réalité
le pays en développement qu'elle aime à
afficher un revendique cela vous pouvoir
vous bénéficiez des biens qu'elle a
tissés depuis 1955 depuis avril 1955 à
bandes ou avec les pays du tiers-monde
dont beaucoup de pays africains et vous
avez
des pays africains qui eux véritablement
n'ont pas connu d'évolution positive et
donc ses relations à se retrouver à
partir du moment où la chine et a engagé
une stratégie de réforme et d'ouverture
économique à partir de décembre 1978
s'est rendu compte la chine qu'il lui
fallait impérativement retrouver ses
liens fraternels et idéologique avec les
pays africains pour une autre raison est
économique parce qu'elle avait besoin
des ressources naturelles du continent
alors justement justement est ce que
cette image du dragon et l'autruche est
toujours à l'ordre du jour parce que
côté chinois on vient chercher des
matières premières en afrique et côté
africain on cherche évidemment des
investissements à des infrastructures
est ce que ça résume bien l'intérêt
mutuel des deux pays y compris
d'ailleurs à l'échelon parce que ça
résume bien finalement la relation
afrique chine absolument vous savez
c'est une relation qui est bâti sur
des intérêts disons en apparence
convergent
la chine a besoin non seulement des
matières premières mais les marchés des
france culture mais également d'un
espace pour déployer son ou voir d'où
son soft power afin de gagner les voix
africaines voix qui lui ont été très
utiles dans son évolution souvenez vous
le 25 octobre 1971 quand la chine a
retrouvé la chine continentale le siège
qu'occupait taiwan à l'assemblée
générale de l'onu et au conseil de
sécurité après la guerre
civile chinoise
1946 à 1949 dans la chine a le plus
baissé ce siège c'est grâce aux voix
africaines donc la chine clairement
à vérone intérêt a toujours un intérêt à
déployer sa stratégie de pouvoir en
afrique de l'eau du coq et le pays
africains que les ressources naturelles
qui ont marché il ya des possibilités à
offrir à allait partir et qui vont le
chercher à diversifier leur partenariat
pour ne pas être seulement tributaires
de leurs anciennes puissances coloniales
ou des états unis évidemment voyez en la
chine ce partenaire qui voulaient
nouvelle pourra toujours très bien dans
votre pays au sénégal par exemple il ya
un an le secteur de la cacahuète a été a
subi une forte demande chinoise ce qui a
provoqué des tensions des manifestations
la chine est devenue le premier
importateur de cacahuètes dans votre
pays dans quelle mesure c'est difficile
finalement de canaliser les appétits
chinois sur le continent vous savez la
chine ces deux pays de 1 milliard 300
millions d'habitants ou plus pour qu'un
tel s'intéresse à un produit ou un
marché elle rafle tout et donc ça change
les hommes c'est ce qu'on appelle
une disruption quand elle intervient
dans des pays surtout les petits pays
comme le sénégal ces deux cent mille
kilomètres carrés si une population de
15 millions d'habitants donc pour les
agriculteurs qui font le chic voir la
chine arrivé à priori c'est un atout
parce que le coût que les chinois sont
disposés à pays ou proches cette matière
première l'arachide ou allait enfin aux
choses triturer ça et même ville disent
atteint en faire du lait qui le vendent
en afrique naturellement c'est tentant
alors que pour par rapport à nos pays la
difficulté est que
la chine quand elles viennent elle ne
tient pas en compte
les possibilités et les attentes de ses
partenaires elle vient comme une force
un éléphant et qui leur furent tous
l'intervention de la chine partout en
afrique a changé et même évincer des
acteurs traditionnels les français et
autres ne peuvent pas gagner
pratiquement de marché sur le continent
africain parce que les chellois haut
débit - disons alors il ya eu quand même
un ralentissement de l'économie chinoise
cette dernière année est-ce que ça a
impacté les économies africaines est ce
que ça change la donne sur le continent
oui parce que souvenez vous
au moment de l'ouverture
de la chine et de ses réformes sur le
continent africain la chine va verser
pas beaucoup avec nos pays c'est après
qu'il ya une boum c'est ce que l'on a
appelé le super cycle entre 2000 et 2006
c'est véritablement là où les
observateurs étrangers les partenaires
classiques comme ceux de l'europe est
aussi constatée cette évolution de sorte
que quand il ya eu en novembre 2006 le
sommet chine-afrique au niveau des chefs
d'état qui s'est tenue à à pékin en
présence de l'alors président de chine
hu jintao a les pays occidentaux
notamment européens qui exigeaient des
conditionnalités démocratique et
politique à leurs partenaires africains
ont commencé à se dire si on ne fait
rien la chine va pour prendre de sorte à
l'époque à ce sommet le la chancelière
allemande de l'époque madame merkel qui
va bientôt quitter ses fonctions avait
déclaré nous n'allons pas laisser
l'afrique à la chine la relation à
afrique chine et c'est une relation
véritablement d'égal à égal on a
beaucoup présenté ce partenariat comme
un partenariat gagnant gagnant pour le
continent africain contrairement à ces
partenaires traditionnels que constitue
la france notamment mais aussi les pays
européens l'âge fils dans sa
conceptualisation de la relation fait
tout pour être le frère des pays
africains mais c'est pas une relation
égale ça ne peut pas l'être la chine je
voulais 10 et 1 milliard 300 millions
d'habitants c'est plus de 5000 ans
d'histoire c'est quand même depuis plus
de 2000 ans le pays qui a connu n'est ce
pas le statut d' état centralisé qui a
aussi une géographie une superficie
énorme kelly l'ambition alors que les
pays africains sont balkaniser adama
guèye on va poursuivre on va poursuit
justement sur ce partenariat gagnant ou
perdant pour l'afrique dans un instant
mais on marque à une courte pause on se
retrouve tout de suite dans afrique
connaître restez avec nous sur arte
france
retour dans l'après connecte sur arte
france la chine fait-elle du bien ou du
mal à l'afrique on en parle avec vous à
adama guèye spécialiste de la chine
justement la chine ne conditionne pas
son aide ces investissements à la bonne
gouvernance
est-ce que ça c'est un point positif
réellement pour les pays africains nos
c'est un problème sérieux parce que
l'afrique quand même s'il ya eu une
évolution qu'on avait salué c'est la
démocratisation on apprenait la baule on
a connu les conférences nationales les
pays africains sont assoiffés et les
populations africaines assoiffés de
liberté de démocratie aujourd'hui il y à
une régression de la démocratisation du
fait précisément de ces nouveaux acteurs
venus du sud que ce soit la chine que ce
soit la russie que ce soit la turquie
elles n'ont pas ces nations les mêmes
critères que les pays qui avaient
accepté la démocratisation dans nos pays
dans le cas plus spécifique de la chine
ce problème là se pose parce que la
chine a une approche stats au centre et
ce sont les états pratiquement avec
lesquels préfèrent travailler elle ne
parle pas avec les opinions publiques
elle ne parle pas avec les citoyens et
ne tient pas compte de la soif de
démocratie des pays d'afrique à est pire
ce que l'on voit aussi ce parce que
c'est opacité dans les négociations de
contrat tous les contrats que ce soit
dans le domaine du de des
infrastructures que ce soit dans le dvd
des mineurs et que ce soit dans le
domaine du pétrole du gaz et des
transports plus récemment ces
négociations se font avec des bakchichs
de deux de sable de table tout cela ce
sont des pratiques qui érode les progrès
des pays africains on apprécie la non
ingérence de la chine ça aussi c'est une
réalité ce sont les états les dirigeants
officiels qui apprécient ça si on le
gave plus en profondeur cela pose un
problème parce que la chine consolide
par son action des pouvoirs
ati et apporte des prêts dans des
conditions non négociée à sous le regard
des opinions publiques a en tout cas des
institutions qui sont chargés de
vérifier ce qui se passe dans la
relation sino africaine aujourd'hui les
pays d'afrique est à écouter il sans
doute un peu vos bras et avec le coup vu
ils ont en face d'eux une chine qui fait
semblant de les aider mais n'a fait
qu'une seule concession accepte le
principe d'une suspension du service de
la dette mais le fuselage est mallet de
pardies on va parler de la dette mais
les pays africains c'est vrai il semble
se montrer plus à l'aise avec les
partenaires qui n'ont jamais colonisé
des territoires africains c'est le cas
de la chine apprécié pour ses
investissements dans des domaines
structurants comme les infrastructures
elles mènent des opérations
séduction à la perfection à l'image de
ce cadeau offert à l'union africaine son
siège immense à addis abeba mais ce
n'est pas tout comme nous l'expliquent
les as de cazaux
la ligne ferroviaire reliant nairobi à
mombasa au kenya le barrage
hydroélectrique de soubré en côte
d'ivoire les arènes de lutte de dakar au
sénégal ou encore le pont maputo au
mozambique
le point commun de ces infrastructures
elles sont toutes financées par la chine
créanciers majoritaire de l'afrique
entre 2005 et 2010 737 milliards de
dollars ont été prêtés par l' empire du
milieu à des pays africains
l'équivalent du pib marocain la chine
est partout sur le continent dans le
domaine minier ou ferroviaire mais aussi
dans le secteur culturel avec la
création en 2004 du premier institut
confucius
où l'on apprend le mandarin et le kung
fu le président xi jinping exerce son
soft power de quoi faire dire à certains
que l'expansionnisme chinois à un
arrière-goût de colonialisme mais les
principaux concernés ne le voit pas de
cet oeil c'est pas une fausse critique
en fait toujours est il que aujourd'hui
la d'afrique l'on a envie de changer et
des paradigmes ils ont envie de voir
cette man autre façon de faire les
anciennes colonies c'est tellement
montre les limites dans tel ou tel
domaine et si la chine vienne et offrir
de meilleurs horizons je ne vois pas
pourquoi est ce que on va pas aller
faire le show modèle chinois en 2016
l'institut indépendant afrobaromètre
réalise le premier sondage sur l'opinion
africaine à l'égard de son principal
partenaire commercial
63% des citoyens interrogés ont une
image positive de la chine l'étude est
d'autant plus parlante en afrique
francophone 92% des maliens et 70% des
béninois sont séduits par le modèle de
développement chinois pour richard houis
sous cette opinion puise ses
explications dans les années 60 d'abord
il faut comprendre que déjà à partir des
années 1960 est beaucoup plus près six
mois pas de sens de venir de 75
la chine a eu un essor économique
vraiment encore or au départ des
indépendances la chine et la plupart des
pays africains hauteur haute état au
même niveau donc si aujourd'hui la chine
est perçu comme
et au développement peut-être les
afrikales de souvenirs est que pour voir
le pays et qui avait le même le même
niveau de même pays que nous un peu en
paix avant des années de l'indépendance
est aujourd'hui qui est presque la
deuxième puissance cordiale donc
l'investissement de la chine vient à
point nommé c'est en 55 avec la
conférence de bandung que les
fiançailles sino africaines sont
organisées les premières rencontres
entre les dirigeants de pays asiatiques
et africains les 29 nations réunies
marque la naissance du tiers monde en
opposition au bloc soviétique et
américains en 2000 les relations se
solidifie avec l'organisation du premier
focac le forum sur la coopération
sino-africaine et elles prennent un
nouveau tournant avec la stratégie d'une
nouvelle route de la soie ce projet
phare de cegid pin consiste à relier la
chine au reste du monde grâce à un
énorme réseau d'infrastructure tout en
prêtant l'argent nécessaire au
financement de ce réseau conséquence
l'afrique semble prise dans le piège de
la dette en 2021 à l'exception de la
grenade tous les pays du monde en
situation de surendettement sont
africains
adama gaye globalement la perception de
la chine par les populations africaines
semblent plutôt positive il ya quand
même des questions on l'a entendu autour
du surf ne pas avoir chinois avec cet
arrière-goût de colonialisme votre avis
là dessus tout il s'assied quelque part
normal les populations se trouvait
étranglés par les difficultés
économiques
or quand les chinois sont venus ils ont
commencé à mettre sur le marché
des produits à bas prix ce qui a permis
à la plupart des africains de pouvoir
s'amuser
acheter les téléphones moins chers avoir
des habits des chaussures moins cher
même si la qualité laissait à désirer
c'était quelque chose qui se fait
d'autre part l'arrivée de la chine
élargie c'est l'assiette et je m'étais
un peu le continent africain dans une
position où ils pouvaient négocier dans
ses relations avec l'extérieur parce que
pendant longtemps la relation de
l'afrique avec le reste du monde étaient
dominés après la fin de la guerre froide
par une sur domination pourrait aussi
dire des états unis et des pays
européens
or la chine la russie et la turquie pour
ne citer que ceux là sont venus mettre
sur la table une autre façon de faire et
après il se trouve que de plus en plus
en particulier avec la crise financière
de 2008 2009 les pays africains à puis
on avait vendu le consensus de
washington et les approches néolibérale
du monde occidental pour mieux parler
vrai guitar de thatcher et autres se
sont rendus compte que le fait d'avoir
mis de côté l'état l'état stratège
sociale et solidaire était devenu un
problème mais ce qui qualifie la frime
de colonies 1 chinoise ils ont tort ou
raison mais ce qu'ils qualifient de
colonies il vise à plus long terme parce
que la chine vient en afrique pour
prendre achetés dans des conditions
parfois douteuses pour ne pas du lait
onil des terres arables l'afrique
dispose de 61 % des terres arables la
chine bien qu'ayant une partie
importante des matmut métaux rares vient
aussi en chercher en a fait enfin la
chine dans les conditions comme je le
disais tantôt de négociations avec les
gouvernements africains y met les
clauses qui risquent demain de leur
faire perdre leur souveraineté sur
certains de leurs actifs nationaux alors
on a entendu aussi tout à l'heure le
continent est très endetté des avis de
l'empiré du milieu une dette qui ne
semble pas d'ailleurs à affoler pékin
mais on parle de pièges tout de même
pour les pays africains forcé a
apparemment de céder leurs ressources
naturelles quelles sont les conséquences
de cette dette africaine envers la chine
lâche il a l'âme est mis sur ces pays' a
plus qu'à parce que les pays
traditionnels qu'ils pouvaient financer
les besoins financiers du continent
africain que ce soit la france et
d'autres ne l'ont plus cette capacité
dans le même temps la chine elle elle
propose aussi des alternatives et des
modèles de financement à la banque
mondiale à l'instar de sa banque
asiatique d'investissement dans les
infrastructures l'abbaye qui collabore
notamment avec la banque africaine de
développement ce qu'un instrument qui a
fait ses preuves oui c'est de bonne
guerre c'est normal la chine veut
ramener le monde à l'état où il était
avant le les mictions des pays
occidentaux sur son territoire avec la
guerre de l'opium en 1840 1856 la chine
aujourd'hui se dote de ses propres
institutions sont bill de son propre
business model ce que la chine a réalisé
pour pouvoir faire son entrée sur le
continent africain il l'a fait sur la
base de ce que le japon et d'autres pays
asiatiques ont réalisé
d'une croissance portée par le commerce
extérieur
aujourd'hui la chine se rend compte que
cette stratégie n'est pas la bonne il
lui faut s'attaquer à ses problèmes
intérieurs parce que toute cette
croissance par le commerce était porté
par les entreprises logis sur la côte
est de la chine dans les régions déjà eu
shenzhen guangzhou est aujourd'hui lé
site et les éléphants blancs c'est vrai
qu'on pointe beaucoup les éléphants
blancs offert par la chine au continent
africain mais globalement ses
investissements dans les infrastructures
est ce que ça a été un vecteur de
développement pour le continent on peut
dire que ça a aidé à donner
espace de respiration au pays à
appliquer mais cette dépendance
vis-à-vis de la chine elle est quand
même un caire aujourd'hui la chine qui
comptait sur les matières premières et
tout est en train de réduire pour
réduire sa voilure dans ses expositions
par rapport aux pays africains elle
impose des clic clic elle qui font que
les pays africains sont connus à la
gorge et enfin la chine sait qu'il lui
faut réaliser sa stabilité intérieure
guillet le mandat du ciel l'un des
enjeux aussi dans cette relation pour le
continent africain cc s'insérer dans les
échanges mondiaux en 2019 les échanges
commerciaux sino africain représente
seulement 4 % de la balance commerciale
chinoise
et il ya ce projet déroute des nouvelles
routes de la soie portés par la chine
partout dans le monde même en europe en
asie en afrique est ce que véritablement
elle le continent africain sort son
épingle du jeu et peut justement faire
peser lourd justement dans les échanges
mondiaux grâce à ce partenariat avec la
chine il faut pas se tromper
les nouvelles routes de la soie h tu
prenante de ce que l'actuel président du
chili du pays appelle le siècle de la
renaissance chinoise
cette cellule de la soie sont purifiés
ma destinée à l'asie centrale
c'est par où elle passe la chine qui n'a
pas véritablement d'exposition maritime
veut s'assurer qu'elle ne serait pas
bloquer si demain les états unis ou
soutenus par l'europe faisait des
blocages sur des routes maritimes
importante à son commerce que ce soit le
détroit de malacca nian ou le détroit
d'ormuz donc elle cherche un passant par
l'asie de s'assurer sa
stratégie et lui assure sa pérennité
maintenant pour les pays africains à
tous ces pays africains en bénéficient
c'est principalement les pays qui sont
stratégiques comme djibouti comme le
kenya qui en bénéficient enfin on peut
aussi dire que les chinois dans leur
façon de faire cherche à développer
l'intérieur le tibet qu les îles zhang
legion qui sont pas entendus puis où on
remet en question met soi-même
l'appartenance de la chine les yanks et
des musulmans ouïghours le tibet ce sont
les partenaires du dalaï lama ces gens
là ils sont assez tendues pendant leurs
relations avec la chine dont il y à cet
effort là cette transformation du groupe
business modèle chinois qui veut que au
lieu de s'occuper du développement des
pays africains au surplus de romain
interne et au delà de ça la chine veut
sortir de son exposition au commerce
offert ce qu'on appelle une exposition
aux services comme les états unis merci
beaucoup adama gaye je rappelle votre
ouvrage 1 toujours d'actualité
chine-afrique le dragon et l'autruche
aux éditions l harmattan vous est aussi
l auteur de deux ouvrages otage d'un
état d'une prisons sénégalaises aux
pyramides d'égypte toujours aux éditions
l'harmattan et demain la nouvelle
afrique avec une préface d' ellen
johnson sirleaf l'ancienne présidente du
libéria merci beaucoup adama gaye
retrouver afrique connecte sur nos
réseaux sociaux et en replay sur notre
site arte france ptv merci à toutes les
équipes du mag et techniques pour la
réalisation de cette émission merci de
votre attention à très bientôt dans
afrique connecte sur rt france